welcome everybody starting just a couple
minutes early to give people time to get
on before we actually start the bulk of
what I'm doing today it's great to have
extra time now that things are settled
at the new studio and to be able to just
get more things done and talk about
things we don't usually have time for on
the regular show so I'm going to be
talking about a really interesting
report related to polarization we've
been talking about this really in a few
different contexts for a while and this
report which we'll get to which I'm also
linking to will let us approach this
from a couple of different angles
there's sort of like an Overton Window
angle a unilateral radicalization angle
there are some interesting topics to
discuss in terms of the movement of the
US electorate over the last five to ten
years so a lot of stuff to to discuss
there let me welcome you if you've never
been on one of my live streams before
these are actually live unlike the
broadcast show which by the time it gets
clipped and put on YouTube is not live
anymore by by its very nature this is
live and you can use super chat to ask
questions and send comments I will be
taking questions via super shot as soon
as we're done looking at the study so
feel free to send them in great way to
support the show number three new
members and patrons will get live
thank-yous during the during the stream
so by all means sign up there we do
start the stream this evening with 1717
patrons I don't really plan to open the
phone lines during this stream but just
as an incentive if we were to get to I
don't know 1750 1750 patrons I would
open the phone lines and or play a live
game of chess last time I did that
people enjoyed watching me lose to one
of our viewers who challenged me on LY
chess where I am David Pakman and I
would consider either or both opening
the phone lines or playing a game of
chess if we get to 1705
patrons number four please don't troll
the live chat I was just checking out
the the chat before we started today and
there were there were already people
trolling come on we don't have the time
for that just don't troll and there are
moderators who will ban you if you troll
and you can become a YouTube sponsor now
and get a shout out although I guess
they've changed the name to channel
membership and I didn't update my
graphic so you know there's that so
let's get into the study momentarily the
one thing I do want to mention so
there's a few different things we're
going to be looking at this study called
hidden tribes a study of America's
polarized landscape and I want to
mention a couple a couple things number
one we have talked in about how in the
United States we have not had sort of
parallel or or equal I guess we would
say radicalization and polarization so
like one example those who are willing
to take their political ideology and
turn it into violence right now exist
almost exclusively on the right that's
just a fact you might not like it but
facts don't care about your feelings or
something like that I've heard from
right-wingers and the reality is that
about three-quarters of domestic
terrorism is carried out by
right-wingers most of the remaining 25%
is carried out by radical Islamist who I
believe are right-wing any time that you
let a literal adherence to a religious
dogma push you to real-world violence
that is by definition a right-wing
action and the remaining few percent are
on the left years ago like in the 70s
you had more of what I guess we would
call eco-terrorism and some sort of
so-called liberation movement Sanibel
Animal Liberation and some others that I
think are more accurately assess as left
wingers who became violent at this point
you have the overwhelming majority of
the actual violence triggered by
politics catalyzed by politics have
on the right so that's one way in which
we don't have an equal polarization in
the United States
additionally the extreme left-wing
voices have not moved the Overton Window
of what counts as sort of the valid
spectrum of the debate to the left in
the same way that the extremes of the
right have pulled the political
discourse in their direction as an
example of that
take taxation just just as an example
you have extreme libertarian movements
who which are not insignificant within
the American right that argue for
positions up to and including no taxes
taxes are theft taxes are slavery they
have drastically moved the discussion
around taxation to the right in the
United States in a way that the left
simply hasn't you don't have any
significant movement on the right that
would be the equivalent of that saying
we want 100 percent taxation or take
everybody's money I mean there's just no
equivalent movement and what this does
is it moves it opens the right in a way
that takes the middle and also pulls it
to the right and we could apply this to
other issues as well so it's really
important to understand that in the
United States even though we've seen a
progressive is a ssin of the American
public on a lot of issues health care
for example majority now believe the
government does have a duty to provide
some basic level of care to everybody
regardless of their ability to pay and
and I'm sensing that I'm just a little
bit loud making just a small adjustment
here if I'm not too loud I apologize for
turning myself down we we have now a
situation where the dialogue on a lot of
these issues has been pulled to the
right even though the population has
been pulled to the left health care
being framed as anything anything short
of market health care is a government
takeover for example I think you sort of
get the idea so this is the context
through which we have to look at
polarization it
not fair accurate or useful to pretend
as though radicalization polarization
are kind of 50/50 it's happening
equivalently on both sides because it's
simply not that that's just not the case
and if we pretend that it is we sort of
immediately lose we're immediately
behind so on that basis let's now take a
look at this very interesting study a
study of America's polarized landscape
and I'm gonna skip through I don't know
if you care about the acknowledgments if
so you can look at them later there's an
executive summary but we're gonna start
right here the hidden tribes of America
oh and by the way I don't I don't want
to like have more than necessary lead up
to this tribalism okay let me say a
brief word about tribalism tribalism has
become a really popular new go-to for
people who want to sound nuanced and
even-handed when explaining what's going
on in politics and I know a lot of these
people personally and some I just see on
the Internet and it's become super
popular to say tribalism is the guiding
force that explains every political
disagreement it explains obstruction in
politics politics it explains why we
can't get along and whatever right
tribalism matters there's no question
and and also by the way tribalism has
been a way for some to do identity
politics without calling it identity
politics right because when we're
talking about our tribes our tribes are
our tribes are significantly based on
identity in many cases there's political
identity Shore which is a little
different than identity politics but
it's important to pay attention to the
way in which tribalism has now become a
catch-all for explaining political
phenomena that doesn't really actually
get how issues are not all the same and
it has become a de facto replacement for
identity politics I don't subscribe to
that I don't attribute tribalism as an
answer or explainer to everything that's
going on in the political world doesn't
mean tribalism doesn't exist and on that
basis let's start
into this this study has identified some
sort of its created a spectrum of tribes
or groups and what is very interesting
about this is that if you look at it
you've got let's just go left to right
the margin of error methodology is not
perfect this gives us just a framework
but let's explore it if you look at how
groups are divided according to this
study you have 8% progressive activists
11% traditional liberals I think it's
important we'll look at the definitions
in a moment and that will be relevant
and then you've got 15% passive liberals
passive liberals to me are a very
interesting group because it's
individuals who have progressive beliefs
by and large but are relatively passive
in making themselves known and they
actually enable that Overton Window of
discussion to be moved to the right
despite it not reflecting where
Americans actually are on these issues
26% are politically disengaged 15% are
moderates and then you've got 19 percent
that are traditional conservatives and 6
percent that are devoted conservatives
before even looking at the definitions
which will do momentarily you
immediately see that you have 19 and 15
is 34 you have 34% that are on some
flavor of the left and 25% that are on
some flavor of the right and then you
have people that are politically
disengaged and those who are moderate
disengaged and moderates are 41% of the
electorate according according to the -
this an electorate maybe is not the
right word because many of the
disengaged don't actually vote but right
away we notice that even though the
Overton Window for debate has been
pulled to the right successfully by the
American right wing you actually see
that in terms of ideology the left is
predominant now let's take a look at how
some of these groups are defined
progressive activists are described as
younger highly engaged secular
cosmopolitan and angry traditional
liberals
defined as older retired open to
compromise rational and cautious passive
liberals are described as unhappy
insecure distrustful and disillusioned
and that's why many of those people
aren't actually part of the electorate
per se and that they don't vote then you
have the politically disengaged young
low-income distrustful detached
patriotic and conspiratorial so based on
this categorization the politically
disengaged can exist on the left or
right of the political spectrum you have
moderates who are engaged civic minded
middle-of-the-road pessimistic and
overwhelmingly Protestant which goes to
to what the religious divisions are in
the u.s. traditional conservatives who
are religious middle class patriotic and
moralistic which is important and that
actually gets to why they don't actually
care about the debt they don't actually
care about so many of the issues they
claim to care about they are moralistic
and they care about the ideas of
supporting those things rather than
their their actual support and then you
have devoted conservatives white retired
highly engaged uncompromising and
patriotic this is already you know I
don't love the way in which these
individuals have been categorized
necessarily but it is interesting that
even accepting these categories and
definitions you have a left which is
bigger than the right by 9 percentage
points so what one thing that we learn
from this is that not voting is
extraordinarily impactful you probably
would have known that from the mere fact
that only half of the country votes
which means that very quickly if you can
take a percentage of these moderates a
percentage of these individuals that are
politically disengaged and appeal to
them on terms that resonate with their
values you can very quickly win
elections merely on turnout neither side
actually has to modify their positions
although we do see a positional
modification let's continue consistency
across issues tribe memberships
I've met tribe membership shows strong
robot reliability in predicting views
across different political topics this
won't come as a surprise to anybody
let's look at immigration if you take
two different views immigration is good
for America helping sectors of our
economy to be more successful and
competitive the other side
immigration nowadays is bad for America
costing the welfare system and using
resources that could be spent on
Americans there's a 51 to 49 split which
basically if you account for a margin of
error means that the country is more or
less evenly divided on those two
positions progressive activists are 99
to 1 on the side that immigration is
good on the other side you see devoted
conservatives who are 90 to 10 opposed
basically taking the position that
immigration as it currently exists in
the u.s. is basically bad and you see
that with the exception you basically
see a straight line with the exception
of those who are politically disengaged
that the further to the left you are the
more aligned you are with with the first
view on this issue and vice versa
I find it notable that the politically
disengaged by a roughly two-to-one
margin take the kind of right-wing view
on immigration which going back to our
definitions up here politically
disengaged young low-income distrustful
detached patriotic and conspiratorial
when I see distrustful conspiratorial
and patriotic probably interpreted in
the right-wing sense I think that
they're as categorized the politically
disengaged may be maybe more right
leaning as the categories are defined
here let's take a look at a couple of
others sexual harassment sexual
harassment is commonplace nowadays
versus nowadays too many ordinary
behaviors are labeled as sexual
harassment again it's a pretty even
split in the the population at large the
progressive activists ninety one to nine
and believe that sexual harassment is
commonplace nowadays on the other side
the devoted conservatives eighty eight
to twelve don't believe that a
okay let's think about this for a second
because this is one of those really
important issues in understanding
politics right now I've been talking to
you for years about how there is no rule
that says if you are against abortion
you also would be for low taxes and
would be for an originalist
interpretation of the Supreme Court and
against immigration okay that's a
package of political positions that most
of us who follow politics understand now
are associated with voting for
Republicans there's no actual rule that
says that's how it has to be and there's
something similar going on here there's
no rule that says that if you think
sexual harassment is overblown that
would necessarily go along with the
belief that immigration is bad and that
gets me to supporting the conclusion
that has been demonstrated elsewhere
that I've talked about which is that we
have these de facto sort of litmus tests
that exist where there are packages of
positions that people often
unconsciously end up believing this is a
problem on the left as well I've
actually pointed out that when it comes
to the left-wing anti-vaxxer movement
for example which is rooted in a
distrust of corporations that the
right-wing anti-vaxxers are often more
rooted in either religious beliefs or
distrust of the government the left-wing
anti-vaxxers are more often rooted in or
catalyzed by their distrust of
corporations there's nothing that
actually follows that if you have
progressive beliefs on a variety of
issues you would end up being an
anti-vaxxer on the basis of distrusting
corporations but yet that is a path by
which many left-wing anti-vaxxers have
ended up with that position and the
concern is that these become sort of
unthinking
positions that people take and okay
maybe I'm going off on a tangent and and
we'll get back to that let's look at
just a couple other examples here white
privilege two positions many white
people today don't recognize the real
advantages they have nowadays white
people do not have any real advantages
over others across the entire population
52-48 progressive activists 99 to one
believe that many white people don't
recognize the advantages they have on
the other side devoted conservatives 82
to 18 think that there are really no
advantages to being or being perceived
as white in modern society then you've
got Islamophobia we probably all can
imagine of what where where that goes
okay tribe membership pictured here
progressive activists and devoted
conservatives predicts how people think
about political issues better than
standard categories like liberal or
Republicans Republican so let's pick one
example let's pick let's pick police
brutality okay they make sure you can
see that all right
maybe should I be zooming in on this at
all I don't know does that help
police brutality two views the police
are often more violent towards African
Americans than others contrasted with
the police are mostly fair towards
people of every race among all we have a
51 to 49 average 95 percent of
progressive activists believe that the
police are often more violent towards
African Americans 93 percent of devoted
conservatives believe that the police
are mostly fair towards people of every
race and the the what this study claims
to demonstrate is that more than
Republican versus very conservative or
race that these categories progressive
activists and devoted conservative more
accurately predict where people will
fall on that and interestingly if you
look at those who are very liberal being
very liberal did not come out as
overwhelmingly on one side versus the
other as those who are defined by this
study as progressive activists
looking at people who are white didn't
predict the position on this nearly as
much as being categorized as a
progressive activist or a devoted
conservative in other words if someone
said here is a person's race can you
predict what their view is on police
brutality you would be less able or less
accurately able to predict their view
then if you were told here is a
progressive activist versus here is a
devoted conservative take a guess now as
to which side of this issue they are
okay beliefs of the devoted
conservatives men and women have
different roles this was a this was a an
issue on which there was one of the
greatest disparities between devoted
conservatives and progressive activists
men and women have different roles it's
more important for children to be well
behaved than creative major gap between
the devoted conservative and the
progressive activist purity matters
major difference between the devoted
conservative and the progressive
activist proud to be an American
seventy-eight percent is the u.s.
average 91 to forty five the split in
terms of proud to be an American hard
work will always lead to success that
goes to your belief in a meritocracy a
huge gap between devoted conservatives
and progressive activists and being of
my religion is important to me about a
30 percentage point split there the most
dramatic differences what is the thread
here these are sort of intangibles these
relate to social issues these relate to
issues that are heavily influenced by
religious belief so what we're seeing is
that and we'll see if we actually get
that data the areas where there are the
biggest divisions between the left and
the right in the United States are not
on issues like taxation although
taxation relates sort of to hard work
will always lead to success if you
believe that you you probably are less
into a progress
tax code because you believe that those
who are rich are rich because they
worked hard and those who are poor are
poor because they didn't but these
others don't really relate to that ok
let me just briefly check in and see
what's happening I haven't looked at
what's happening on the stream ok I am
gonna be getting into super chat soon so
if people do have questions about this
or anything else feel free to to to
start submitting those let's continue
with the study beliefs of progressive
activists ok what are the top beliefs of
progressive activists government should
take more responsibility to ensure
everyone is provided for 94% agreement
there men start off with an advantage
91% of progressive activists believe
that people's outcomes are outside of
their control now that's a direct
contrast to hard work will always lead
to success I'm not proud of my country's
history
curiosity matters more than good manners
white people start with an advantage
very interesting the exhausted majority
know that I actually want to dig into
that so much right now
ok devoted conservative stand out on
immigration I think we we probably would
would have guessed that progressive
activists stand out on speech
progressive activists are the least
likely to believe that political
correctness is a problem in society not
hugely surprising the majority of
Americans want compromise desire for
compromise split by wings and exhausted
majority people I agree with politically
need to stick to their beliefs and fight
49 percent of the wings believe that
whereas only 35% of the exhausted
majority believe that the people I agree
with politically need to be willing to
listen to others and compromise 65% of
the exhausted majority believes that
while only 51% of the wings believe that
ok was there anything else that I wanted
to sort of point to here there's a lot
of methodology stuff which is not really
great for a live stream look
see if there was anything else here
there is a lot of really interesting
stuff that that's the majority of what I
wanted to to sort of introduce so what
are our takeaways from from this study
there's a few things that are important
to me here number one when we talk about
who is driving the lack of consensus on
a lot of political issues that actually
does seem to be very evenly polarized
you have both wings the devoted
conservatives and the progressive
activists who so strongly adhere to
their beliefs that they don't believe
that compromise makes sense
or as possible and that is not hugely
surprising what I do find more acutely
interesting is that with the exception
of that sort of meritocracy question
most of the strongest and most sincerely
held beliefs that both the left and
right have don't relate directly to
economic policy in the way that many of
us might imagine or anticipate the the
and that really for me confirms that
when we talk about I mean a favorite
issue of mine is the debt when we talk
about the debt I've been talking about
it being a political football for a very
long time I genuinely don't think that
most conservatives care at all about the
debt and the reason that we know that is
not just because they only care about it
when it increases or they claim it
increases under a Democratic president
and not when there's a Republican
president there is nothing in any study
that I've seen other than when people
self-report how much do you care about
the debt where people say oh yeah yeah I
care about that when it's fed to them
I've seen no data that actually suggests
that people genuinely care about debt
and deficit when it's useful to malign a
candidate you already don't like you can
use that the left also falls into this
and I've seen this as a major problem
for the left playing the same game that
the right plays with the debt when we
have fundamentally different beliefs
about the debt at least many of us many
of us do so I don't know how we get out
of this I don't know what this actually
tells us about what the paths sort of
forward are because if people aren't
even if you ask individuals what are the
most important political issues to you
they are unlikely very unlikely to
actually name the ones that feature
prominently or relate directly to what
was most important based on this studies
results so how do you even engage with
people when they don't even realize
which political issues are actually the
most important ones to them I don't know
the answer and I'm actually interested
in hearing from people about that I
don't know if you how do you even
establish a conversation I recently had
a really interesting conversation with
Nathan J Robinson from current affairs a
lot of people didn't like him some
people don't like his accent but I
actually thought the conversation with
him was very interesting and you can
find it archived on the YouTube channel
and I proposed to him or I guess I asked
him about whether we should be on the
Left trying to appeal to the right by
making arguments for our positions based
on values that appeal to them so like as
an example most people on the Left don't
object to the death penalty on the basis
of it being expensive right like for me
I understand that the death penalty is
more expensive than someone being in
prison for life
I get that that's the case but even if
it was cheaper it's not going to change
my view which is against the death
penalty for so many other reasons
reasons that have nothing to do with the
cost so the question is should we try to
convince conservatives to be against the
death penalty on the basis of the values
that are important to us or should we
make an argument that maybe would appeal
to them like about fiscal conservatism
Nathan J Robinson said it's not a good
idea to try
to kowtow to people's values when they
are not your own that in the long term
it's not effective well if you don't do
that then what do you do what is the
basis on which you can appeal to those
individuals and and I genuinely don't
know what the answer is to that I'm open
to hearing from people and you can by
the way if you if you joined us into
this thing we are doing a livestream you
can use super chat to ask questions and
to send comments new members and patrons
get live thank-yous if you sign up on
our website or via patreon and please
don't troll the live chat I I haven't
noticed too much trolling but I have not
been paying super close attention I
please don't roll and I don't know if we
actually have any of our moderators in
right now hmm
seems like there's a guy named Tony who
is trolling quite a bit that's not
that's not ideal but I just am I've got
a lot going on here so I'm having some
difficulty moderating the chat okay
let's let me get into some of the super
chats that are going on this is an art
show crust BOP sent to $10 super chat
with try very much appreciate asking can
you predict how bad anti-semitism will
get it seems like immigrants and Muslims
face the most abuse in the Trump era but
now anti-semitic conspiracy theories are
just stating in online pits like gab
yeah you know so actually let's see if
we can divide up and categorize a little
bit so you've got all hate crimes then
you have as a subset of hate crimes
religiously motivated hate crimes of the
religiously motivated hate crimes hate
crimes against Jews are the most
prevalent and and actually have been for
quite some time so I think that it's
going to continue getting worse
unfortunately and you're absolutely
right that one of the issues we're
having is that anti-semitic conspiracy
theories have been fomenting and growing
in a lot of the online
recesses of the internet under the Trump
era
I've talked extensively about how it
really doesn't matter whether Trump is
personally anti-semitic or not there's a
lot of people who every time we talk
about this say David why why are you
insisting Trump's anti-semitic his
son-in-law is Jewish and his daughter
converted to Judaism and he has Jewish
grandkids I've never actually said that
I remember and if I if I did I saying it
but I don't think that I've actually
said because I don't believe it that
Donald Trump is personally anti-semitic
what Donald Trump has done is he has
coalesced and catalyzed the white
nationalists and the anti-semites and
those who love to talk about George
Soros and the Federal Reserve being
controlled by Jews and this type of
thing he has signaled to them by talking
about America first and being a
nationalist and all of these other
things that he said that he said it
doesn't really matter whether the guy is
personally anti-semitic this doesn't
matter I don't really care
III don't know if he is and it's
irrelevant to the conversation so
because of that I fear that it is
actually going to get quite a bit worse
and I know I'm in touch with a lot of
the groups that are very active on this
issue and it's something that I I don't
know if and how it's going to be
resolved but it's it's a real problem
and a lot of a lot of people believe
that actually it's going to get
significantly worse before it gets
better particularly if Donald Trump's
reelected in 2020 because they will be
even further emboldened and feel
vindicated in a sense although why I
can't really say for sure it's not
really vindication okay Terry James has
sent a $5 oh by the way thank you to any
ghost and who was this other new and
William masseur both of whom have been
become channel members on YouTube Terry
James $5 super chat if Trump is removed
or resigns before 2020 would Mike Pence
be easier to beat in the election I
think
he would be if the Democrats don't get
it together and i-i've said this before
I think that establishment Democrats
have no idea how difficult it's going to
be to defeat Trump in 2020 and if they
run anyone who is not up to the task of
beating Trump at his own game
this doesn't mean making fun of disabled
reporters or saying that Mexico or some
other country are mostly sending rapists
I don't mean playing the game in that
way but if you don't have someone who's
really equipped to take Trump on in
terms of the way that Trump has created
really what would be called in the
marketing world sticky narratives that
stick around if this includes the
branding of other people that he has
done successfully little Marco and lyin
Ted crooked Hillary crazy Bernie all
that stuff
Democrats will get absolutely crushed if
they don't understand how to run against
Trump and it has nothing to do with
Trump's policies being good it has
nothing to do with Trump being competent
he's quite the opposite in fact and it's
going to be it's it's going to be tough
to defeat Trump no matter what happens
between now and 2020 art Flores has sent
a $9 99 cent super jet Black Friday
seems to highlight the contrast between
the rich and the poor as of 2006 there
have been a total of 10 deaths and 111
injuries but I digress
what are your opinions on Black Friday I
do not participate in Black Friday in
any way so I when I was in high school
and my first few months in undergraduate
at the University of Massachusetts I
worked at now-defunct retailer Circuit
City I have told a ton of stories from
my time there and in fact if we get to
how about this if we get to seventeen
fifty patrons at patreon com slash David
Pakman show during the livestream I will
tell what I call I hate to even say it
because it's so vile I will tell the the
rogue pooper story from when I worked at
Circuit City
if
people have been watching the show for a
while you may be familiar with that
story already if we get to 1,750 patrons
not only will I thank every single one
of you I will tell the Rogue pooper
story from Circuit City but in any case
maybe it's better that I not tell that
story when I worked at Circuit City
black frightened Black Friday was like
the best thing in the world and I
remembered that I was in high school and
sometimes on Black Friday as a
salesperson you could make a thousand
dollars in commissions because it was
just crazy we would work in teams and
one of us would stand at a register
trying to sell people extended service
plans where our teammate would be on the
sales floor pre selling stuff and then
bringing people and it was fun but even
then as as someone working inside the
retail system I realized the big deals
aren't really that great like yeah okay
you could get a surge protector that was
like a penny after a mail-in rebate that
took months to get or something like
that but by and large if you were a
savvy shopper and paid attention
throughout the year you could get pretty
similar deals so in that sense you know
there's a couple ways in which we could
say that Black Friday is a contrast
between rich and poor on the one hand
you can say Black Friday is for people
whose economic circumstances only allow
them to buy certain things when they are
as discounted as they are on Black
Friday the other side of that class an
education issue would be Black Friday
preys on people who don't understand
that if you're a savvy shopper you can
get pretty similar deals year-round and
in in in both ways you can kind of talk
about the rich-poor divide but I think
Black Friday is horrible I think going
out and lining up the day before is
horrible and when I say that I don't
mean that I am not sensitive to the
plight of people for whom consumer
electronics or bulk toilet paper
purchases or whatever are outside of
their financial means
I recognize that and I talk about that
the program all the time but Black
Friday isn't actually about getting
people deals on the things that they
need year-round and sometimes can't
afford it's about getting people to buy
a lot of crap but they don't need stuff
that's often surplus or beeline what we
would call it Circuit City and I think
it's horrible and I simply don't
participate okay the great John says
what's your take on mmt meaning modern
monetary theory couldn't get a gauge on
your interview with stephanie kelton
thanks I am sort of on the MMT side in
the sense so modern monetary theory
takes the point of view when it comes to
debt and deficit that we can't just say
debt bad surplus good deficit bad
surplus good we're paying off the debt
is always good what matters is why are
we in debt why are we running a deficit
and that if you run a deficit to give
rich people tax cuts rich people who
have a low what's called marginal
propensity to consume meaning if you've
got a lot of money someone gives you a
little more you're not that likely to
spend that money going into debt to give
rich people a tax cut is not the same as
going into debt to make sure everybody
for example has health insurance which
makes it so that people don't miss as
much time from work because they have
health care that they can they have
health services they can get and afford
which makes it so that they earn more
wages and then the government takes in
more tax revenue because those people
aren't calling out right so the point is
a billion dollar deficit increase to
give a tax cut to the rich is not the
same thing as a billion dollar tax cut
increase to spend money on education for
example which leads to a better educated
population and people earning more money
and committing less crime which means we
spend less on police so I subscribe to
that completely do I subscribe to the
idea that it literally makes no
difference how much money we print no I
don't think I don't take that to its
full extreme but I am very interested in
mmm tea and and we'll continue doing
interviews about it
Green says what is the political
consequence whoa
scroll down there what is the political
consequence for the Trump administration
and the Republicans trying and
successfully getting rid of daca I
thought I don't think Republicans are
going to do it I think ultimately what
Republicans are doing is they are
putting up a stink on immigration so
that their what would we say so that
their base feels that they're doing
something but ultimately they're not
going to deport kids who came here
through no fault of their own and when
they were kids and their parents were
undocumented so I think they basically
want the benefit of kowtow to the base
but they're not going to take the
political consequences of actually
deporting kids who came here because
their parents decided to bring them here
I see someone who sent a super chat that
says Heil Hitler I am gonna ban that
person and so that users messages will
be hidden we're never gonna see their
stuff again and I will remove that
message I guess we keep the dollar
ninety-nine though so hope that was
worth it the best ever for seventy five
five dollars will debunking the myth of
meritocracy win over conservatives I
think it will I okay so question one if
you were to successfully debunk the myth
of meritocracy would it then convert
conservatives to a different economic
worldview maybe maybe the more pressing
question is what would it take to
convert conservatives about their being
a true meritocracy and I've said before
that when only half the country votes
you can get 10 people to vote much more
easily than you can convince one from
pused to change their worldview so I
think if you were able to convert people
over into believing understanding we
don't really have a meritocracy that
might be impactful but I just simply
don't think that the amount of work
that's required in order to do that
actually is is the best time investment
because you can change election results
just by getting people to vote okay I'm
getting pinged by
a ton of new members here just take a
brief respite here okay so let me just
say a quick thank you Kathy would milton
Wells John Sheffield bill Needham and
Mark Ernest all have signed up for
memberships at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you to all of you thank
you to all of you and keep signing up
really really appreciate that okay uh
kori Gorski sent a ten Canadian dollar
super check David in your opinion how
much of modern-day right-wing ideology
is directly inspired by religious based
beliefs so let's see mmm
some of these are difficult to answer
because there's a few layers current
right-wing ideology is very much
inspired directly by the religious based
beliefs of conservatives thirty years
ago many of the conservatives today no
longer adhere to the religious beliefs
but they still follow the conservative
doctrine which was established and
influenced by those religious beliefs 20
to 30 or even 40 years ago if that makes
sense
River Gibbs what are your thoughts on
Elizabeth Warren in 2020 I aligned with
much of Elizabeth Warren's politics one
of my recent live streams I actually
took a the I side with political test
and I was mostly aligned with Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders so I would be
interested in seeing her run I would be
interested in seeing a Bernie run and I
actually think there's a pretty good
chance we're heading in the direction of
both them that of them running based on
the folks in DC that I've spoken to mr.
black $2 thank you you are truly an
intellectual I really don't think so I
actually I I truly don't see myself that
way I see myself as someone who is just
trying to learn from actual
intellectuals and I always feel like I
am lacking such knowledge and it is not
false modesty at all believe me if you
talk to people who know me personally
you would know that but I
she ate the super chapped debar new
sends a 10 Canadian dollar super chat I
moved to Toronto to get away from Trump
I'm happier than ever he's doing stuff
Supreme Court appointments tariffs
pulling out of international agreements
that will out his last presidency and
that will out his out last his
presidency sorry and it still stresses
me yeah you know at the beginning of
Trump's presidency I would regularly say
on the show yeah Trump's an embarrassing
disaster but a lot of the stuff he's
doing can be pretty quickly reversed the
geopolitical damage the tariffs the
destabilization and debasement of
American politics and democracy a lot of
the stuff he's now doing is not going to
be undone easily and that is a that is a
major concern for me as well charmander
carnelian Pikachu says Oh Jett at 2020
how exactly is Trump doing a bad job
well how is he doing a good job I guess
if you believe that the president has
achieved any kind of measurable positive
results then you have to make that case
right I mean if you think that the
economy is good because of Trump as my
buddy
Jesse Lee Peterson argued when I was
interviewed by him in Los Angeles a few
weeks ago he you you have to make that
case and when I said to him well okay so
the stock market market has gone up
although we seem to be regularly having
500 down 500 days for the Dow tell me
what he did to achieve that and of
course he couldn't and on geopolitics
relationships with the rest of the world
are worse than ever
unilaterally bailing on the Iran deal
when Iran didn't violate the Iran deal
is an absolute and total embarrassment
and why would anyone do deals with the
US when you have the justified belief
that you could do a deal you could stick
to the deal and then the next president
might just say we're out of the deal
why would you ever do that there's been
a total destabilization of the currency
market for the dollar I'm and have a big
story hopefully on tomorrow's show
if we get to that about that issue as
far as Oh Jetta 20/20 I don't think he's
the guy period and I talked about that
on today's bonus show and if you sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership or make a $5 a month
contribution on patreon you will be able
to hear me talk about that today Marc
Tenenbaum $2 what are your thoughts on
the fiduciary rule okay so the fiduciary
rule is a rule which says that there's a
legal requirement for financial advisors
to work in the best interests of their
customers and I basically think that
it's one of those rules that is not
really enforced and thus it has very
little in the way of teeth this applies
to Realtors as well realtors in so I
don't want to get into a whole thing
about Realtors but in states where
you're not allowed to have dual
representation meaning that the realtor
represents both the buyer and the seller
there's a lot of states where that's not
allowed where the buyer of a piece of
real estate has to be represented by one
realtor and the seller is represented by
another realtor the realtor is required
to represent the best interests of their
client specifically does that always
happen of course not because the realtor
for the buyer only makes money if the
buyer buys so the interests of the buyer
are to pay as little as possible for a
property the interests of the realtor
are for the deal to get done at the
highest possible price that their buyer
is willing to pay I'm talking about the
buyer's agent here so how do you enforce
or even demonstrate that they must act
in the best interests of their client
when they literally don't have the same
interest and you could say well if the
buyer but walks away the buyer's agent
gets nothing because they work on
Commission so they do have an interest
in a deal that works for the buyer yes
they do but they have an interest in a
deal being made at the highest price
which the buyer is willing to pay
anyway with the fiduciary rule it's
similar financial advisors now I speak
from some experience on this I have an
MBA and financial planning and also have
a ton of friends who are pretty high
level financial advisors and basically
they have to be able to demonstrate that
they were acting in a reasonable scope
for in the interests of their client but
there are actions taken all the time by
financial advisors when it comes to
recommending to similar products one on
which they make a higher Commission
that's not necessarily the better
product for their client happens all the
time I mean literally this stuff happens
all the time I am in favor of the
fiduciary rule I just think that it's
it's simply not enforced and it's it's
very it's sort of like prosecutions for
perjury we a lot of us know perjury when
we see it but it's very difficult to
prove intermediary Joe asks is abortion
illegal eyes door justified murder no
it's not I mean I I've been talking
about this for years I don't know that
that there's too much more to say
numbered sent a $2.00 super chat Sanders
O'Rourke 2022 much to hope or dream for
on the bonus show today check out
today's bonus show become a member or a
patron because it really was a good
bonus show we talked about whether
someone like beta O'Rourke who just lost
would make a good presidential candidate
because aside from whether we like his
positions is there sort of a bad omen
element to taking someone who lost and
saying now run for president I don't
think beta O'Rourke is my choice for
nominee for president for Democrats for
2020 but I actually would be pretty
interested in seeing him as a running
mate and I think that Sanders O'Rourke
is an interesting one
mr. politics 365 says are the days of
centrist presidential candidates over
Kasich Tim Kaine Michael Bloomberg etc
you know I don't know the answer to that
and part of it is related to this idea
of unilateral radicalization that I
talked about it
the beginning of the stream you raise a
lot of money not by playing to the
middle but by playing to your base and
as a result of that I don't know that
there really is a big opportunity for
someone like Kasich or someone like
Bloomberg although I happen of this sort
of cohort I tend to be more of a
Bloomberg guy although when I took my I
side with political test I think Kasich
was the Republican that was most in line
with my political beliefs which is not
hugely surprising I don't know I don't
know whether there is a space for them
in the future of politics
Browdy Andrew Mulligan $2 explained the
benefits of eating hamburgers upside
down oh man yeah this is this is
arguably my most controversial belief
and let me see if I can demonstrate this
oh how can I do this if I have maybe
I'll take this piece of paper so I've
described how I eat burgers before let's
imagine that the writing on top of this
piece of paper if you imagine a burger
the the writing is the sesame seeds
right meaning that the sesame stop of
the bun is on top
I never realized until probably like
five years ago and I talked about it on
the show when it happened that most
people pick up a burger and they sort of
bring it to their mouth with the sesame
seeds on top you understand what I'm
saying and what I have always done is I
would pick up the burger see that I flip
it so that by the time I bite it the
sesame seed bun the top of the bun ends
up facing down and it just felt natural
you pick something up and you bring it
to your mouth this thing never felt
natural to me and that's basically it
and now it's just too late I've been
eating all sandwiches like that when I
have a baguette sandwich okay you have
kind of like the more curved part of the
baguette on top because of how the the
bet bread rise
I take that that curved part and I flip
it and at this point I think I'm just
too far gone and I don't I don't know if
there are actually benefits I don't
think that I guess depending on the
condiment placement if the condiments
are placed on top if you flip it now the
condiments are on the bottom when you
bite you won't get the condiments stuck
to the roof of your mouth or mostly on
the roof of your mouth which I guess is
a nice thing I don't know what am I
talking about let's move on to the next
one Daniel Marable says do you think
Trump being in the media is having the
side effect of promoting popular ism in
other countries such as my in Australia
okay so I understand are we saying you
mean populism the the thing about
Trump's version of populism is that it's
right-wing populism and as a result it
actually foment authoritarianism that
that's the thing it's sort of like so
what we're seeing in Europe the rise of
the extreme right in Europe is really
more connected to a very specific sort
of authoritarian right wing populism
authoritarianism that comes from
right-wing populism so it's possible
that Trump is having that effect but
it's not actual populism in terms of how
it manifests once someone is in power if
that makes sense your man says should
the left start trolling to combat
right-wing trolling memes are fine but I
don't think that trolling should be the
platform of the left numbered says super
chat to let you know that Tony fat is
trolling the chat let me take a look at
that yeah this this guy is toxic I'm
just gonna make let's see can I put him
in timeout hmm I just did something and
I don't know if it worked I deleted one
of his messages and I was tie he was
timed out okay so he has a five-minute
timeout yeah I should just ban him he's
listened if I'm noticing when we have a
chat that has a message every three
seconds and I'm noticing
someone there's probably a problem
there's probably a problem
okay let me uh what do I want to do I I
do want to say thanks to a few more
members and patrons we let's see here
who do we have Daniela Robinson has
become a $2 a month patron and
unfortunately we're still at 1717 which
is where we started so someone probably
cancelled their patreon contribution
during the stream which is which is
unfortunate also I want to say thanks to
Kelly Richmond Kelly Richmond has signed
up at WWN pakman.com which is very very
exciting and I appreciate that so it
seems clear we're not going to hit 1,750
patrons if we get three patrons and just
get to 1720 I will play a game of chess
against someone from the audience if
someone wants to challenge me to a
five-minute game on li chess I'm David
Pakman last time people like this and I
I lost and I played someone who's way
better than me so if we just get three
patrons okay if we get to 1720 you can
start sending challenges now on Li chest
I don't mind embarrassing myself I'm not
that great at chess player but it can be
fun to play against people from the
audience
send me a it's got to be a five minute
game because otherwise it's just gonna
go on and it's gonna become very boring
for people start sending me challenges
on li chess I am David Pakman if we get
just three patrons if we get to 17 2004
the end of thee before the end of the
stream okay din child asks via super
chat have you ever been convinced of a
right wing argument I don't know I don't
know that I've ever been convinced of a
right wing argument I have had
areas and I thought I just did an
audience question about this last week
areas where I don't particularly
disagree with Republicans but it's
relatively uncontroversial stuff where
Republicans and Democrats left and right
are just kind of not so much aligned but
it's just sort of like obvious
low-hanging fruit but I don't know I'd
have to think about that I can't really
think of any area where I've truly been
convinced by a right wing argument there
there have been times where I've
realized that I just don't know enough
about an issue and need to learn more
and that applies to I mean that's
applied to the first amendment that has
applied to there's really a lot of areas
some economic issues but I don't know
that I've ever really been been
convinced by a right wing argument where
I say wow I need to abandon my left-wing
beliefs no I can't think I can't think
of such an issue okay
I've received the challenge on Leech s
from the little Gumnut this could be a
good game okay if we just get three
three patreon contributors at
patreon.com slash david pakman show it
can be a dollar a month I will play
against the little Gumnut and I will
probably get crushed because I'm not
that good at chess but it will be
entertaining for everybody and we can do
that before the end of the stream JB $5
super shot the right ties Islamic
violence with the left the left buys
into the narrative that Islamic violence
is totally different than right-wing
violence
so let's this is actually a really
important thing
and thanks to Red Scare who has just
sent a $5 pledge we just need two
patrons and I will play against that Lee
chess individual so this is really
important I consider Islamic violence
right-wing and the reason that I
consider it right-wing is that if you're
devout Christian beliefs lead you to
commit violence or your devout Islamic
beliefs lead you to commit real-world
violence either way those are extremist
right-wing authoritarian dogmatic
beliefs that are not aligned with any
left-wing belief or value that I can
identify so I actually agree with you JB
we sure
consider Islamic violence right-wing
violence in the same way same way that
white Christian dudes in the u.s.
committing violence for political
reasons
unless it's stated like if a Christian
or a Muslim says I am so against the
ignoring of climate change that's going
on that I am going to go blow something
up okay that that's pretty clearly
connected to something on the right and
it seems like their religiosity is
incidental but if your beliefs are so
devout that they are what move you to
violence in the real world that is
right-wing plain and simple and I think
that it's we should be considering
Islamic violence right wing the reason I
mention it when I say about seventy five
seventy four percent of domestic
terrorism is right-wing and then another
twenty or so percent is radical
Islamists and then what's left is
left-wing I do that because the right as
you point out has successfully separated
right-wing and Islamic violence and I
want to be sure that people know what
I'm talking about but you're just
completely right
it's not fair to do that and Islamic
violence is right wing in the same way
that Christian violence is right wing
mark Tenenbaum says thoughts on the
Israeli nation state bill I actually
have not seen it I've been so wrapped up
in the elections that I haven't seen it
and I plan to look at it and I will
probably do a segment about it
let's see James Montalbano says does
having a family make someone more
selfish and thus more corruptible should
we embrace more single political
candidates that's interesting the idea
would be I guess that if you have a
family someone could get you to do stuff
on the basis of threatening your family
on the basis of doing something that
would affect your family and if you
don't have that family then you wouldn't
care it may be true but if you're
looking for me to get behind single
politicians that's not a hill I'm even
remotely interested
in climbing to the top of never mind
dying on but I do think that that is
interesting ravaged time okay so but by
the way let me just remind you we are
two patrons away from me accepting a
challenge from someone watching the
stream on Leech s and playing a game of
chess against them and I often get
crushed that's okay I'm willing to do it
they've sent me a challenge I will
accept it if we just get two more
patrons support what we do patreon.com
slash david pakman show very slow night
on patreon which is why we have lowered
the target to just two more Red Scare
just sent a $5 pledge which is great
meaning we just need two more patrons
even a dollar a month will do it and
then I'll play a little game of chess
before we wrap up ravaged time says if
you support vaccines does that make you
a vaccine side effects denier would you
support the use of fossil fuels for the
same life extension legacy huh okay so
I'm not sure I understand part two
question one is if you support vaccines
does that make you a vaccine side effect
and I or the answer is no you can I mean
listen I support vaccines when I get my
flu shot I have the side effect that my
arm gets extremely stiff and painful for
two days that's a side effect I don't
deny that I have sometimes experienced
24 to 36 hours of cold like symptoms
after getting my flu shot I don't deny
any of that stuff and I'm for about
vaccines so now part two is would you
support the use of fossil fuels for the
same life extension legacy I guess what
you're saying is if we needed to use
fossil fuels for vaccination would I
support that I don't know I mean it's
it's just it's a little bit a little bit
out there
mark kehna mom says you say raising the
corporate tax rate helps investment
spending as it is deductible while this
may help us companies will it stop
foreign companies debating moving to the
US and create a race to the bottom okay
so you're talking about
I guess the macroeconomic impact of
raising the corporate tax rate versus
the micro economic
in fact it's sort of a non question in
the sense that effective tax rates in
the US are already extremely low and
thus raising the effective corporate tax
rate in the US would still create
incentives for foreign companies to move
here because the tax rate would be lower
than it is where they are and it
wouldn't change anything about the
deductibility and it would still be a
reasonable tax rate so I think that we'd
have to do the analysis on that and it
no longer the the thing when you start
considering the tax rate of foreign
countries you're now making a different
economic analysis that's not just what
does the u.s. do and how how does the
u.s. do it a Kendall Lynx says a problem
that I see with publicly funded
elections is that celebrities like Oprah
and Trump have an advantage by
popularity voting absolutely I read a
very interesting article by the way
about Oprah today which pointed out that
not only is she if she were to run on
the Democratic side in 2020 doing the
same celebrity thing that the right is
doing which we could debate whether it's
good or bad
she has given rise to so much
pseudoscience just so much pseudoscience
that she truly has no place in national
elected office she gave rise to dr. oz
she gave rise to all sorts of New Age
healers and all of the stuff that is
progressives we should be completely
against and I didn't realize until I
read this article the extent to which
she was responsible for that and I I am
I am not supportive of the draft Oprah
movement
okay Ryan Cespedes has just become a
patron meaning one more patron one more
patron and I will do a live chess stream
against one of our viewers the little
Gumnut who wants to challenge me on LY
chess I am David Pakman on li chess I
will play a five-minute game if we get
just one more patron to at least do
something good to know
on the patreon side one more patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
we will trigger that game atthe Sarge
asks hey David do you follow European
politics I do although not as much as I
would like to I follow the politics of
Spain because my stepmom is from Spain
so I'm more tied in and following
Spanish politics I have been following
the rise of right-wing nationalism in
Europe but I don't follow like if you
asked me about the details of what's
going on in Norway politically right now
I would not know and I should know and I
want to follow that more closely
Matthew long asked why haven't you
covered the floor to recount I did
actually today's broadcast show contains
one or maybe even two stories about the
Florida recount we've been off since
Friday so most of that has been
happening while we were off I covered it
today I will probably also cover it
tomorrow and it's disgusting by the way
that in in talking about the Florida
recount we covered Donald Trump saying
that there's voter fraud in the fact
that uncounted ballots have surfaced
which of course there's no evidence for
whatsoever sean hannity said that
someone should go to jail over the
recounts that are taking place in
florida rick Scott the presumed
Republican elect senator although maybe
the recount will change that and current
Florida Governor nodding along on Fox
News as Sean Hannity said that someone
should go to prison for what's going on
absolutely just absolutely vile and
disgusting what is going on in Florida
with that recount and I did cover it
very important story what I didn't get
to cover today but I will cover tomorrow
is that Democrats have actually lost one
fewer seats in the Senate than we
thought because Kyrsten Sinema has now
in a in the counting of uncounted
ballots reached an unsurmountable
insurmountable lead against mcsalley
what is mcsally's first martha
in Arizona so we will have the first
democratic Arizona senator from
Arizona's in the US Senate since 1995 I
believe and Democrats still no control
of the Senate but it's better than we
thought and that's just a fantastic
thing multi-talented asks do Democrats
generally fail to engage voters in
persuasive rhetoric rhetoric like
Republicans do on that topic topic I'd
love it if you talked with destiny again
I would like to talk to destiny again
I've been making this case for years and
George Lakoff makes this case that
Republicans are just better at framing
and use of language they do have the
benefit of simple positions on a lot of
issues like taxes are bad let's lower
taxes or abortion is murder
let's out why and Democrats
conservatives Democrats progressive
leftists don't have equivalent equally
simple positions and that is to the
detriment of the left for sure and it's
a big reason why we have not seen the
success that the left should have had on
many issues despite actually being more
in line with so many more Americans on
basic issues okay
Brody Mulligan has just sent a dollar
super chat which means that I am indeed
going to go ahead and face off against
the little Gumnut on Leach s let's see
what I can do
let's I'm accepting this challenge what
is this how are we how was there already
a game in progress I don't understand
this hmm I don't get what's going on
here the game hasn't started but pieces
have already been moved I don't get this
hmm oh the little Gumnut says hold on I
guess we're doing a new game rematch
here we go
alright here we go I'm gonna play
against the little Gumnut little Gumnut
to be fair you should turn down the
stream to not hear me discussing what my
strategy will be even though it would be
on a delay I just think that that that
would only be fair let's see if we can
get this going here I get crushed so
often and it's not good rematch offer
was sent why is the game not starting
and I'm not seeing a challenge either
hmm imagine if after all this we can't
even get the game started see here we go
all right I'm black I'm not good at but
not racially I just mean in this game
let's see what we can do here so far so
good I usually take here
although yeah I will take then I will
move here if I took the knight the Queen
would just take my night and then that
wouldn't be great
mm-hmm sometimes unsure in this position
actually what it is I should be playing
this is uh f7 just a notoriously weak
square for black and now I will have to
move my night away could also trade
nights but then the Queen would have
pretty solid position fact I think I
will do that I think I have something up
my sleeve if I move here I can fork this
is actually actually a good move I think
he made a mistake
yep was able to take his Queen pretty
early didn't even see I'm like so bad I
didn't even realize that that was
actually on the table what will he do a
lot of people would actually have
resigned here after losing their Queen
so early but I'm not going to do that I
am going to play it out I'm glad he
didn't do it why would I resign
do i trade now I don't
here it's kind of a pointless check I
think I'm just going to bring out my
night sort of underdeveloped here would
like the castle got a couple of pieces
protecting that Square discover check
forking the pond that was really stupid
why did I do that
I want to kick that away this should be
an extraordinarily winnable game given
how early I took the Queen there's
actually some interesting positions here
have to move the rook can't take my pawn
because then the knight takes
should probably get one of my rooks in
play here if people are giving me advice
by the way I'm not looking at the chat
that would not be fair last time I saw I
went back and looked at the chat and
people were angrily telling me what to
do so it doesn't seem like that would be
fair at all and that seems like a major
major blunder giving away the rook don't
want to give away the rook and the Queen
that's not good okay and he or she
resigned gotcha
all right well haze listen I actually
won I actually won a game which is
exciting let me take a quick look back
over here see what else is going on
leland chu ha new member thank you for
signing up Daniela Robinson five bucks
since it seems Trump can do no wrong to
his base do you think he has a high
chance of being reelected yes I do
Daniela yes I do and I've been talking
about this for a while and it is one of
the great concerns great great great
concerns which is that if Democrats
don't play this thing you might think
this guy is bonkers and he's obviously
going to lose if Democrats don't play
2020 perfectly Trump is going to crush
them Trump is going to crush them
significantly and seriously and you are
absolutely right that does it for me
today thanks to everybody who joined me
thanks to everybody who made the chess
game happen sign up on patreon
sign up for membership we've got to
support independent media I believe that
the next two years are definitely the
most important since I've been doing a
political show and probably the two most
important years in my life
politically and that says a lot that's
it for me today new show tomorrow thanks
for joining